ah bonjour à tous je reviens de chez
ricoh depuis leur lancement où
effectivement on a pu récupérer le view
de proto joli sac wiko bon je vous dis
attention cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisé donc rassurez vous ce concert
dans cette vidéo c'est qu'on va faire un
boxing du tout nouveau view de pros on
va regarder s'il intéressant oui ou non
et puis quelques temps entre est ce
qu'on fera ses contrats un test complet
je vous ferai un retour mais pour leur
direction le hand of things
qu'est ce que j'ai dans le jeu les sacs
alors ça c'est intéressant j'ai quoi
hein on va à l'aneth le fameux view de
pro j'arrive à la trappe et voilà le
vieux de pros ça c'est super on va faire
un vrai hein de boxing et puis on va
regarder s'il intéressant oui ou non
d'ici quelques secondes ensuite qu'est
ce que j'ai encore dans le reste du sac
rico j'ai un petit carnet pour pouvoir
prendre des notes écrire merci beaucoup
et qu au fond de la caverne d'ali baba
on y va directement à la caméra j'ai un
stylo des jolies lunettes
donc on va faire cette vidéo en mode
découverte du sud de pro on va regarder
s'il est cool louis non moi je trouve en
tout cas la boîte vraiment sympa bon pas
l'intention je veux les en dés parce que
je préfère pourquoi dit droit dans les
yeux je trouve que la boîte est plutôt
cool comme ça maintenant on va l'ouvrir
on va regarder ce qu'attend on va
regarder si c'est intéressant oui non
comme ça au moins on pourra se faire un
avis concret sur la bête le prendre en
main et voir au final s'il est cool si
les à-coups ça tout ça voici ici la
boîte du fameux viau de pro je la trouve
plutôt cool sur le principe j'aime bien
ce sens la boîte ça change un petit peu
de ce qu'on trouve ailleurs donc on voit
bon la batterie si vous avez en effet un
petit peu brillant jeu plus comme on
appelle ça l'effet pellicule et c'est
plutôt pas mal mais bien en relief
alors vous avez un peu les specs
derrière un vous le voyez fullscreen un
écran 6 pouces 16 mégapixels caméra
selphy double caméra à l'arrière 16
mégapixels la stabilisation vidéo c'est
une stabilisation numérique un pas aux
optiques vous avez si le faisceau noc un
processeur oak d'accord on va quand même
ça tout à l'heure plus en détail
vous avez 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage du nfc pour pas mal de choses
alors on va ouvrir un petit peu tout ça
voir ah ça c'est sympa quand on ouvre
déjà tombe sur le produit wilko game
challenger c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait son poids on a
parlé de joueurs la vidéo qu'on a fait
directement avec mes potes de rester
connectés ils l'ont fait remarquer et je
trouve que c'est vrai c'est un produit
qui pèse son poids je vais comparer et
je vais prendre un produit un peu
anciens 1,5 c voilà il est quand même un
peu plus lourd est-ce que j'ai mon homme
et j'ai regardé avec mon smartphone
6 s tu trouves un peu plus lourd bon
après c'est pas non plus un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment déconné alors avant de
regarder directement de l'ouvrir en
vache tactique osée dans la boîte voir
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur donc on a ça
ici qu avons-nous ça s'ouvre à j'adore
le câble de recharge c'est du micro usb
on a ici des petits bouffons c'est pour
le casque je suppose
le casque que j'ai ici 10 et idéateur
ouais c'est pas mal ça c'est plutôt
plutôt bien fait plutôt bien pensé ici
forcément votre adaptateur pour pouvoir
le brancher paf sur le secteur est en
dessous qu'est ce qu'on a à des
consignes de sécurité le safety book du
vieux de prob ont bien à lire je suppose
ici nous avons merci 5e et je vous en
prie ou ico ses traits avec grand
plaisir
le guide de démarrage ça c'est plus en
plus rare d'avoir des guides de
démarrage donc pour tron doit on doit
dire que c'est plutôt bien fait
effectivement une prise jack
le cas pendant tant d italie le flash
dont 2 jusque là on est un peu des ports
qui sont grandes ouvertes
mais bon il ya des gens qui peut-être ne
savent pas ne comprennent pas donc peut
permettre effectivement de voir un petit
peu tout ça je trouve que c'est bien
c'est plutôt bien pensé plutôt bien
faits peut donc avoir soit une double
carte sim soit une carte sim une carte
microsd pour ajouter de la mémoire
extensible jusqu'à 128 giga donc bon sur
le coup c'est pas mal c'est plutôt bien
fait intéressant est là qu avons-nous
c'est quoi c'est un porte-clés wiko puis
comme mobile why not bon mais le contenu
est plutôt bien c'est bien d'avoir mis
tout ça alors que la plupart des
constructeurs sont vraiment sur des
trucs hyper minimaliste au cou ou mikko
mais des objets de dons c'est plutôt
bien voilà on va pas pas dire le
contraire alors maintenant vraiment le
produit je le prends le directement dans
les mains
à quand il coule on va pas se mentir
c'est vraiment un beau produit moi
j'aime beaucoup je trouve que d'un point
de vue purement esthétique déjà on a un
don au brillant vraiment il était
vraiment kelly un grand format qui tient
quand même relativement bien dans la
main
lorsque je le prends comme ça j'ai accès
directement ici au capteur d'empreintes
digitales donc vraiment bien fichu et
lorsque je louvre j'adore les petits
bouts et ça c'est top top grand écran
ici vous avez effectivement votre petite
encoche bon sur le principe tout ça pas
mal alors on va regarder après parce que
effectivement bas vous avez une grande
bordurie s'il envoie qui délimite
l'écran on a discuté le jour c'est un
petit peu le coup de gueule de givet qui
disait effectivement bon ça pourquoi est
ce qu'ils nous font des encoches en eau
pour gagner de la place et en bande nous
fout des grosses bordure je suis
d'accord avec effectivement à prayssas
n'a produit quand même qui n'est pas
très très très cher donc bon on va pas
non plus pour aller là dessus le bouton
ici pour l'allumer vous avez le bouton
de volume
le capteur je vous disais tout à l'heure
ici votre emplacement pour mettre votre
carte sim la prise jack ici cool et ici
votre port micro usb pour pouvoir
recharger votre smartphone
on va l'allumer vite fait et puis après
on fera un test plus en détail un peu
plus tard parce que les effectivement on
exclure une partie de unboxing je sens
la petite vibration oui qu android alors
il faut savoir que là dessus quand même
on a un androïde 8.0 oreo on a une
batterie de 3000 milliampères heures du
bluetooth 4.2 du nfc un snapdragon
qualcomm snapdragon
octo cores cadencés à 1 8 giga hertz ou
lol oui cogent déjà pas mal d'animations
lui l'élu view de pro c'est assez classe
je trouve ça plutôt pas mal fichu
voilà j'ai accès directement à la bête
bon on fera un test un peu plus tard là
pour l'instant l'idée est effectivement
de voir l'une boxing alors vous voyez
effectivement l'encoche ici on n'a
aucune partie je sais on a des bords
malgré tout alors c'est pas un bord à
bord donc bon on va pas non plus
s'attendre à voir un truc de dingue une
partie effectivement une grande barre en
bas grande bord durant ma part dont on
n'a pas se mentir ça fait une grande
bordure une encoche je sais pas si ça
aurait pu faire autrement après je
trouve que d'un point de vue design au
point du plan esthétique où il cause
mais un petit peu dans les normes des
nouveaux designs actuels
ça évite effectivement d'avoir des trucs
avec des grandes banques des comptes
bordure en bas ça change c'est sympa
c'est un produit que je trouve en tout
cas moi plutôt plutôt bien réussi il est
un peu plus lourd que la moyenne
et encore c'est pas non plus flagrant
mais bon pour avoir un produit qui est
vraiment bien fichu je trouve que voilà
moi c'est un bon produit
comme je le disais aujourd'hui on parle
que d'eux boxing si quelques jours on va
faire un test vraiment complet donc je
vais le prendre je met ma carte sim
je vais me balader je laisse courir et
faire des photos à droite à gauche des
souvenirs ailleurs ce soir je vais aller
voir des potes donc on va se faire une
petite vidéo avec ça on va voir ce que
la caméra dit on va voir si elle
intéressante oui ou non je pourrais
avoir des choses à qui peut du reste ça
va être ça va être marrant mais bon on
va sur le principe je trouve quand même
plutôt bien réussi je trouve que le dos
et bien fait voilà je suis plutôt
satisfait du produit déjà sur une
première prise en main je n'ai pas une
découverte parce que j'ai déjà eu au mwc
à barcelone au mois de février dernier
donc je le connaissais je sais déjà
rencontré j'avais pas vu effectivement
tous cas met dans la boîte et je trouve
que pour un coup oui cosmos vraiment pas
du monde c'est vraiment un
joli une jolie boîte - trouve que voilà
ça c'est plutôt couleurs maintenant on
va vraiment se concentrer là-dessus voir
s'il intéressant oui ou non et donc
d'ici quelques jours je vous fais un
retour complet d'ici là je vous invite à
vous abonner à marquer toutes vos
questions suggestions en commentaires si
vous avez des questions sur ce produit
des choses collègues le test que joue en
particulier vous bleu marqué je vais le
regarder très rapidement ils vont tenir
compte pour mon test et puis je vous
dire un petit peu ce qu'il en est donc
marqué moi tout ça en bas comme d'hab
vous naissez des jolies pouces vous vous
abonner au resto qualité parce que
d'éléments il ya papa plein de trucs
hyper cool qui arrivent des grandes
nouveautés des surprises des concours
des cadeaux il ya plein de choses et ça
c'est super cool donc merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo a très bien
peu soyez sages et je vous embrasse ciao
ciao
[Musique]